i want to ask you so we're going to go
through the project and i want you to
tell me your favorite albums from each
of these artists well obviously it's got
to be give it your diatrion for 50. oh
yeah of course
immense that goes what i'm saying by the
way massacre super slept on
yeah um but what about i mean you say
your favorite
was 808 your favorite album since you
used the heart nah that's your just was
assembled it makes sense uh graduation
graduation just like bro that
was impeccable it's a great body of work
it's like
i don't know like i think everybody
likes to say my beautiful dark twisted
but
that that guy i'm a late registration
guy oh also older older kanye yeah i
love late registration
yeah graduation was solid and i just
i don't know man i'm like i'm like i'm
not as high as graduation on on
graduation as everyone else why not
it's a great app look kanye's gotten the
best discography ever
yeah he's got a great discography i feel
like late registration and college
dropout were like brother sister albums
it kind of sounded
i didn't hear that much evolution in the
in the body of work they kind of sound
very the same
nah late registration had john bryant on
the production it was so much more
like that's the same i feel like they
could they could be a deluxe album
of each other i disagree um all right so
let's say the jump from late
registration to graduation those are two
completely things different things
late registration i feel like the jump
from each album is very different
i don't know i feel like those two are
in the same ballpark i feel like my
beautiful dark twisted fantasy is his
best album
because you really can't say [ __ ] and
then it's really up to you to say what
your favorite is
yeah yeah they're they're two closest
they sound sonically closest they're the
they're the closest out of any two
yeah yeah graduation yeah
yeah i just got into an argument with
somebody and
youtube was killing me because i said i
like jesus more than graduation
i um it's an unpopular history this
isn't king and he's a city
oh you're [ __ ] crazy it's at the same
level very unpopular opinion in hip-hop
yeah i love jesus nah no jesus is king
he goes somewhere else with that yeah
[Music]
yeah he was slapped on though yay was a
good album because i feel like nobody
really talked about mental health that
song ghost town
yeah yeah it's hard to make a better
song than ghost town man
that song was crazy wouldn't leave was a
great record too yeah for sure
for sure for sure yeah yeah yeah was
slept up and then kid see ghost was like
yeah i feel like kitsy ghost is sleeper
for like one of the best kanye projects
ever
yeah i've never really i know no lie no
cap i've never really been a cuddy fan
like that
it's crazy i've never really been a
cuddy fan no i mean that's fair because
i'm i'm
uh i wouldn't say i'm the biggest cuddy
fan either
i like doses of cuddy it's it's
it's it's like sit through a whole
project to cut he's
probably harder for me yeah like my
favorite cuddy project is when he was
like still like really rapping like he
had a project called a kid named cuddy
a mixtape sponsored by ten deep um and
then
you know the man on the moon [ __ ] is
cool people love it
um like you can't tell [ __ ] to a kid
cudi fan
because they'll be like he's the
greatest ever yeah i mean
you guys you you met those kind of
people right yeah bro i mean
yeah those kid cudi fans are [ __ ]
crazy
but i get it like listen man this music
is a beautiful subjective thing and i
love cuddy like you know
in doses i just you know i feel you on
that yeah he got his he's got his niche
audience
for sure sit where he sits but i got my
my taste and my flavors uh okay what
about uh jake
what's your favorite cult project all
right so my favorite cold project is
definitely born center
okay that's a great body of work if not
if not more centered in 2014
but those are really you know forest
hills drive is kind of like the
consensus
yeah but that's what he's born centers
that's when he got the respect he that's
when he got disrespected he deserved but
born center
came out the same day as jesus bro but i
what
i think don't get enough credit is those
truly yours eps that he put out yeah
my god those body those little projects
was crazy i think uh
for just like uh nostalgic purposes i
really enjoy
i still like love friday night lights
friday night lights was crazy he was
that's i don't know i feel like he was
just
some super duper duper and the warm-up
was crazy yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know what's crazy is
like
with cole like he bounced back i was not
a fan of his first album
because there's so much old [ __ ] on
there so much leaked [ __ ]
and you know what he did on that first
album we mean you were just talking
about he was like purposely trying to
make radio records yeah
the disease because you remember like he
couldn't get an album out
like they kept stalling his [ __ ] out and
then like you know there was like mr
nice watch and workout and all that [ __ ]
it was cool
but like you said i think born center
was like the first time he just did what
the [ __ ] he wanted
yeah i think where he met the enough
some some [ __ ] for the critics and
[ __ ] for the crowd i think that's where
he finally okay this is a hard one
kendrick because
i mean he's three for three if we're
talking major releases obviously if you
throw section 80 in there he's four four
but like
i mean kendrick's got no misses on his
uh yeah kendrick is hard i think
i'm gonna say good kid man city because
i felt like he literally was telling my
story bar for bar
like i'm talking about like hitting a
house and [ __ ] like that and
friends getting murdered and all like
literally word for word bar for bar i
was like
i was i was hurt like yo god why are you
letting somebody else tell my story like
this man is telling my story so that
that resonated me
with me differently and then i liked uh
to pimp a butterfly because sonically
there it sounds like nothing i've ever
heard
yeah if you put a gun in my head i would
say good kid bad city but p peppa
butterflies right there too
yeah and also to pimp a butterfly was
like
it's aged so well yeah when it came out
it was just i feel like it was over
everyone's head
yeah nobody could handle that i don't i
don't think we were ready for that after
after
sec i'm not not secretary at the uh kid
we was like yo
i have to listen to it a couple times
and as i listen to it i'm like wow
and then damn is just the [ __ ] you
know just press play it's
hit hit after hit after yeah bro [ __ ]
all right last one drake
that's a tough one i would say as far as
albums is either going to be take care
probably take care
take care i want to say uh so far gone
because that project
did a lot for me when i first heard it i
was like yo this is out of here
but uh i said take care if y'all listen
to take care bro that's hit after hit
no for sure i hate when the hip-hop head
say drake don't have a classic album
it's like yo bro damn
bro that's me yeah i say take care is
the closest thing he has
you know what's hot take care not a
classic album well i'm not even saying
it's not a classic album because it
might be a classic to me and to you
but i just don't feel like it's like a
consensus classic
like you know how like you say like good
kid mad city it's like an undeniable
classic
take care people argue whether or not
it's a classic
and and so i i think take care as a
classic personally for me it's a classic
there's a lot of albums i pers
i just don't think it's like a like a
undeniable
consensus classic album like you know
when you say doggy style get rich or die
trying like
these are albums like nobody will ever
say anything different take care
is close but like you said there's a lot
of people who say drake doesn't have a
classic album
i think take care is a classic i just
don't think it's like
it's not a consensus like yo undeniable
nobody's going to say [ __ ] to you if you
say you know
equipment i from outcast is a classic
like who's going to say it like you know
what i'm saying
take care there's some there's some you
know some
there might be an argument i had this
argument with my manager the other day
and i was like go back and play the
album because i think a lot of people
don't realize that all those records
were on that same house right
right right a lot of times because drake
had a he drake has had a crazy run he's
still in his run right
but at that time he was just literally
like he owned the radio he owned all the
spaces
put kendrick on there yeah bro like yeah
kendrick had his own record on there
right
so um when you go back and listen like
how many hit records he had on there
that weren't like even four radio that's
just like yo this is just
drake you know i think you'll you can
say that one as a classic i don't know
what
whatever crew levels on there right yeah
yeah crew love yeah
yeah bro you know i don't disagree with
you i think it's a classic but i just
think that it's not like
you know i think i'm just waiting for
for drake to drop a project that like
upon first listen you're like
oh my god and i'm not saying that take
care is not that
but i just mean like you can't say [ __ ]
about good kid mad city
yeah no like if someone told you like
nah that ain't a classic you know like
like you'd be like
you're like shut the [ __ ] up but a lot
of people whose opinion
you would respect and hip hop might not
say to take care of the client i just
mean
it's a classic to me to you subjectively
we all have our own classics you know
what i'm saying
but i just don't think drake's got that
one that like there's no argument for
i think the reason why i take care is in
the classic because it's not a themed
album
i think the skits on good kid mad city
is what makes it this classic body of
work the same thing with
uh tipping the butterfly or even them
it's like it's a cohesive body of work
to where you cannot
deny it and creatively it was like a lot
of
just risk taking yeah i just think yeah
i i don't know man
i love drake um nothing was the same as
my favorite drake album
but i do think take care in my book is
classic yeah um
i used to the nothing was the same
clouds because that's more known
really yeah the clouds is like when you
see those clouds oh you're about the
clouds on the album cover yeah
oh yeah i put that i was in my favor
that's my drake my favorite drake
project i just a great album though yeah
but it made sense you know exactly what
i'm talking about
looking at those clouds it makes sense
so yeah